hello and welcome to two people about to
make a mistake
why tom
why because a few weeks ago i was on
marcus brownlee's podcast uh we talked
about doing this they had the sauces in
the back and then we just went to lunch
and forgot about it and i drove off and
you remembered but now i'm here well i
asked a few people and you were the
first person to say yes i did say yes so
this is my fault equally entirely
entirely um
so the producers have sent over a stack
of questions and answers i've not seen
these you've not like steamed the
envelopes over i haven't no these just
these just arrived
they're all estimation questions so
they're all like number answers
furthest away in each round tries that
rounds hot sauce we start easy
we end up at this end and i really the
reason that we're not just testing all
the hot sauces first lots of people have
done that and second i really don't want
to do this one
i really so that one's worse than this
one
every time i watch hot ones which by the
way we don't have permission from them
like we hope you don't mind
i hope you enjoy the free publicity that
you really don't need um
everyone taps out on the bomb just here
right and the rest like they're just too
far gone that's the one i'm i'm worried
about
how are you with hot sauce i've i've
never i've done
habanero hot sauce
i don't know where that stands in this
about two or three i am screwed
so this is hot one's classic hot sauce
this is meant to be the mild one this is
meant to be for for everyone so um
good luck i'll uh i'll open question one
which have been decorated with a little
fish then but
is that on theme like is it i don't know
i think they just had some fish stickers
and use them instead of numbers all
right
how many tennis balls are used during
wimbledon every year ah yeah this is not
a brain's question
how many tennis balls are used during
wimbledon every year and wimbledon
there's a lot of matches that yeah
several courts
all right
i think we're gonna have different like
orders of magnitude answers here ready
yeah twelve thousand oh eight
sorry
eight okay we're both in the same order
of magnitude you know it's it's yeah
no one's no one's got a number in the
hundreds no one's put a hundred thousand
in there do you wanna do you wanna pull
the answer
if this is ten thousand we're in trouble
what happens then we both do it okay
easy i just made these rules up on this
spot
the answer is
55
okay we're both out
but you were out more so the first ones
first one's yours crack the bottle okay
uh we got tortilla chips uh instead of
chicken wings uh because a we don't want
to rip off their format entirely and b
these are much cheaper
good dollop yeah solid dollop okay down
the hatch
graceful
i would have i would have put the whole
thing in my mouth rather than trying to
i'll do that moving forward yeah yeah
you know it definitely registers that
one yeah all right which is very
worrying that's very worrying question
two question two
what is the equatorial circumference of
the moon in kilometers
okay
okay i'm not immediately panicking at
this
because i know what i know roughly what
the earth is
and i know roughly the gravity of the
moon
i'm just i'm just in big numbers like
this is
here's a question do you think you'll
eat any sauce today i will be very
surprised if this isn't 50 50.
true
i mean i heard some zeros over there
i've just realized that
i've written the exact same number as
last time i've written twelve thousand
[Laughter]
i again a horrible feeling that this
might be too nil because
the earth is what like 25 000 miles or
something
yeah it's it's like i was thinking it's
about 30 000 k 40
wow
you've definitely got this i don't i'm
not sure i have
because the trouble with that is it's
got a squared in the formula
i'll tell you this we're both very close
but i'm ever so slightly closer it's 10
900.
oh this is uh adobo loco island wings
pineapple cayenne pepper sauce you are
very much going in the shallow end here
now that shouldn't do too much that
should be
yeah all right
definitely tasted pineapple we've got
we've got water we've got milk none of
that coming into play yet mm-hmm all
right i'm just going to pre-write eight
thousand yeah
number three this is uh this is hot ones
brown sauce this is los calientes
uh ingredient number one in this is
chili's so we are already quite a way up
there great
oh how long is the first video ever
uploaded to youtube
i remember what it was yeah i remember
what it was
they're at the zoo weren't they
yeah it was it was called mia
yeah
mainly mainly for the solid crew
reference i've gone for 21 seconds
two minutes
was it that short i was it that long oh
it probably was that short wasn't it
would you start with two minutes i don't
know i mean it's your answer
18 seconds
yeah i just thought they would have done
more at the zoo you know
looks
there's no no flushing happening yet
yeah no that was uh all right that's
sort of getting to
not a problem but it's becoming one
all right that was the first one that
sort of continued after i finished
eating it but all right still not too
bad uh your question my question your
question
[Applause]
name the other slow mo guys
someone that i can win how many people
attended the first festival held at
worthy farm in 1970.
so that's glastonbury the first
glastonbury
is that what that
is have been called glasgow the phrase
that really carefully
well done to the question team because
first glastonbury festival i think is
different to first worthy farmer but i
think worthy farm is glastonbury if it
isn't that whole section will have just
been cut out
this is the first one where i i have no
idea which ballpark to start in same
i mean the common answer is for me to
put 12 000 down again
but
i think i'm gonna have to go
i mean it's a question for a reason it's
going to be an interesting number
or
maybe glastonbury was just on while they
were writing these questions
all right
so i uh i did not go with the same
number i went with 1200
it's almost like we've got the same kind
of brain for jokes
i don't know why i put a comma there
though i mean i have a horrible feeling
that if you'd have gone just a little
bit because i think it's actually way
now i've seen these numbers i'm like
that's gotta be
it's gotta be more than that surely it's
gotta be more than that if you put
anything higher than that i would be
worried oh my god i'm so sorry it's
fifteen hundred hundred
not bad aren't we both we're both right
you invite someone on the channel and
you then you just treat them like this
i'm sorry which or which hot sauce is
this by the way this is this is seventh
reaper seventh reaper does that mean
there's carolina reaper in this oh it
does oh good
that was a sarcastic oh good just to be
just to be clear yeah yeah all right um
i'll say this to you now mm-hmm uh it's
been a pleasure being on your channel
yep how's it no
this may be one of the last things i say
yep yeah
the thing about tortilla chips is you
have to chew them no matter what you
can't just
yeah yep you can't swallow it like a
pill
how are you feeling
all right all right
if you've ever thought about learning to
code then the free fundamentals camp by
this video sponsor boolean might be for
you boolean is a tech academy that can
get you from zero to building a basic
website in a few hours for zero cost if
you want to get started with coding and
after a few hours end up with something
that you can proudly say you've made and
completed yourself boolean's
fundamentals course is available on
demand whenever you're ready to begin
their full courses are live and online
with actual instructors and projects
they're for people who are looking to
start a career in tech you can choose
between front-end development full stack
or data analytics with a money-back
guarantee that says if you complete the
course apply to find jobs and then don't
get hired they'll refund you or you can
choose to pay them only when you find a
job but the fundamentals camp that's
free it's an excerpt from one of the
full courses and if you've thought i
want a code but i don't know where to
start well that might be a good place to
try without any monthly subscriptions or
any payment at all click the link in the
description to find out more and maybe
start coding your own website
right
back to the show
uh question five oh
i mean it's called burns and mccoy
mezcaline oaxacan hot sauce
i'll be crawling out of here today hmm
trying to see if i have a sheen yet how
many words are in shakespeare's longest
play hamlet what font was he using back
there
quill
i can't put 12 000 yet i can't no
shakespeare's longest play
so it's
it's a decent
chunk of a book that right how many
words are on a page how many words can
you say how many words can actors say in
three hours is it three hours it feels
about three it feels about five hours um
this is a good question these are really
good questions
because they're all ones i feel like i
should know the answer to
okay
what'd you put
80 000
i put 25 000.
okay so what's in the middle of these
two the middle of these is 50 something
thousand
[Applause]
and it is
it's 30 000 sorry hell
hell's bells
i'm really sorry gab i just got to get
better at guessing these were the ones i
wanted to try gav
these are the ones i'm like i'll do
these these are fine i'll i'll these are
the ones i'm worried about and then
sorry
so that's the end of the front half this
is
this is normally still reasonable
i think this one was worse you know
really
slightly
i mean the biggest ingredient in that
one was tomato so
the next one is collards and ghost this
is colored greens and ghost pepper
uh i remember being in alabama with
destin from smart every day love him and
he was impressed i knew what colored
greens were
this was they're not a british thing no
i never have them
i'd never had them until i came here
same with like grits and stuff yeah
god
how big is the world's largest ikea in
square meters in square meters
oh where meet it so you've got to take
you've got to work out how big it is and
then like multiply
what's a football pitch
i actually don't know how big a soccer
field is i know a american football
bridge is going to be 100 yards which is
about 100
meters so that's gonna be about a
hundred by thirty so that would be
three thousand
yeah i feel like i've got my maps wrong
there that's about right a yard is what
like 91 centimeters yeah yeah this at
this level of estimation yards and
meters are about interchangeable part of
me is like i need to you know i need to
i need to absolutely get some um
get some hot sauce down me in this video
or i just look smug like i need a
comeuppance here but also part of me is
wondering if i can clean sweep this
because i'm i'm really over competitive
i have to redo the intro about the two
people about to make a mistake yeah
800 000.
i've done i bet the smallest one is
bigger than that
i thought i figured a kilometer by
nearly a kilometer and now that seems
way too big in my head
so a thousand by a thousand would be a
million would be a million yeah it it
might be more than a million that might
be the worst
guess i've had
65 000 i was way out i was way way out
really
65 000 square meters
i feel like ikeas are bigger than that
you get lost in them yeah it's it's very
hard to i was thinking like massive
there must be a massive american big box
store i've seen like kilometer by no
it's you're spot on
right it's very hard to comprehend when
there's a square involved in the field
okay oh the clean sweep i'm so relieved
oh boy this is i ah this is phenomenal
i'm so glad you invited me also i'm
coming in at hot sauce number six here
i've had no warm-up
all right collards and green hot sauce
oh all right that's that's a lot that is
going on in the deep end there and i
kind of want to pour some of this off
but i can't reasonably do that at this
point i think i think i should be like
yeah we gotta okay
here we go
good night tom scott no i love her good
i mean they are gonna be food aren't
they they can't be all horrendous it's
it's not mild
i'll say that much
that's not mild
it tastes delicious they've made a
really good hot sauce it tastes like
collard greens
that hits the back of your throat
really quickly
yeah i'm really strongly and i think
that's the factory feel
that flush okay i'm gonna see it are you
getting like the clagginess
happening yeah
all right
excellent
this video is heating up
that's a it's a good hot sauce kind of
already want some of the water but
i'll keep going
number seven is turfing's tire things
curse yeah turfing's curse all right
ingredients yellow red pepper
red onion vinegar
baby carrots orange juice where are the
chillies
apple cider vinegar oh here we go
habanero ghost pepper scorpion pepper
my tongue's on fire i didn't like the
last bit no i didn't either that's
weirdly the underside of my tongue is on
fire interesting how'd it get under
there
i've noticed very liquidy i did make the
mistake i don't know if you saw i don't
know why i did this i got the chip and
then i sort of turned it 180 degrees and
poured the hot sauce directly on my
tongue i don't know why i did that
number six is a hell of a thing to come
in on that's yeah i don't know
when was the first electronic
spreadsheet invented
i read an article about this a few
months ago and i can remember none of
the details
it's going to be for like one of the
early pre-pc things isn't it
we probably shouldn't talk to each other
get the ideas on here but
so i
i was torn here i thought it might be
like lotus 123 or something like that
for like early max in which case i've
gone way too early but i feel like there
might be something like sinclair
spectrum or something like that
so i said 1981
ah
well
your answer that's uh well no what were
you thinking
i just thought it'd be some sort of
somehow like electromechanical thing
that they figured out
maybe
because it would have been have to have
been after the
graphical user interface wouldn't it no
no cause i was thinking like you could
do that on a keyboard just with
characters yeah
1979.
you are on it i'm on it i i just assumed
it would be a a pretty extreme answer
but
you know i think possible turfing's
turfing's curse so that was that's the
worst answer yet i think for me
i mean i did say the biggest ikea was
nearly a million square feet so
when i miss i miss hard i missed by a
couple of decades there all right uh
here we go
[Applause]
i mean you're not immediately yelling in
pain so
i think i might be all right okay you
can just sort of feel this
right it's like you can feel the upward
spike and you just don't know where it's
going to land yeah so some of them are
coming like
yeah
i think that one's already
we're on number seven there's no water
there's no milk yet i'm proud of us well
maybe we should start adding a little
bit more as we get up there i guess
that that's that's going to come back to
haunt us
well that one i'm really feeling it on
there
okay uvula area
oh hang on
it's de bomb de bomb evolution this is
the one that kills every interviewee
this is the one that's the first
ingredient is red hot chili peppers
what is the average temperature of the
earth
during the 20th century
in celsius
huh
i don't know i'm wondering if you've got
a lot of polar yeah i'm wondering if the
poles really skew the average to a nice
medium i was thinking that and also
you're gonna have
it's an obvious thing to say you're
gonna have a lot of winter
yep
i was very surprised to find that do you
know what percentage of the population
is in the northern hemisphere
oh i mean if that's a question coming up
i'll be impressed but i'm going to
assume it's like high 80s 90s yeah it's
like almost 90. yeah
okay hang on we
i'm just going to pick the most average
place i can think of in terms of weather
and pick the most average weather that
it could have
i'm thinking
mediocre autumn day in milton keynes
13 19
you probably have this i'm not sure i
was just in the back of my head thinking
you know like
i said no i'm singapore i think i think
i've got it wrong because it because
deserts deserts although it's very cold
at night a lot of them that's true
so if this is 16 double bob double bomb
sorry
13.9
it's an it's an average
it's a mediocre autumn day in milton
keynes
gab i'm sorry i really am i honestly i
can't be annoyed because you're so close
to these answers you are within
one degree of that i wasn't planning
this i swear i assumed this was going to
be sort of 50 50. this is the worst case
scenario because it's not 50 50. and
there's no clean sweep no no so it's
really just as bad as it could be for me
without being a clean sweep feeder yep
uh which which like in terms of inviting
guests onto this channel being a good
host uh appearing graceful and not smug
on camera uh it's also i'm not in
physical pain but let me tell you
emotionally and like from just sheer
awkwardness i feel terrible i feel i
feel really bad all i'm learning is that
for par for round two of this when we
eventually do another collaboration um
i get to pick the game
i didn't even have my nose over it
that has just set every saliva gland in
my mouth into overload like something oh
my god
okay yeah yes that's a little bit of
that yeah
that is that's a solid choice that's
sorry i swore there um
that's okay we'll bleep it i suspect
we'll be doing a lot more bleeping very
shortly um
good good night
talk it through what's it like
it's wet at the moment okay this is not
immediate oh my god okay
oh my god
this is bad okay
oh it's still going up oh no
oh god
and i've just swept
i'm trying not to grin still honestly
it's still going up this is this is the
one i didn't want that's
if
i have to reset my whole scale okay
everything else was a one okay
my tongue is getting bigger
is it expanding
all around
it's climbing the walls
i can't open my eyes
i think it's still building there
there's a lot of spit happening
okay
okay
i want to move and run around
yeah take it take it walk it off yeah
maybe a little straight just a little
the middle of my vision is good yep
all of this is fuzzy
like a snowy sort of
what's this so the next one after that
is less than that it's meant to be
i feel like i want a hiccup
i just
just don't know like what you need water
position is okay
maybe uh
water milk i'm gonna try for i just want
to see if i can
get to the top of the hill you know
without it yeah okay
but um
i might be over the hump okay
that one like invaded my entire face
yeah i
could feel it moving through the veins
of my face the first words you said were
it's it's just wet
and then
then it went places
yeah you know i'm gonna have a little
sip yep i think water can make it worse
is that right i don't know uh i guess
we'll find out
okay so
the problem is just trying to shift the
rest of it the residue
oh there's little pockets of it
so now we know that if you are if you
are doing a hot ones uh taste test uh
you can you can start at like five
you can start there
yeah these are just
nice those are just nice hot sauces some
of these were worrying that that had a
bit of a kick but it went very quickly
that yeah one of these got me worried
because i could feel the potential ahead
and then it sort of
it just left the building all right
how old was the oldest dog on record
i assume it's in human years
um although that's actually like a clue
isn't it they say what a doggie is meant
to be like seven of a or is it nine yeah
but you think of some cats who
can push about 18 i think i don't know
why i'm trying to
give you some
benchmarks here uh
what oh wait what as of what year as of
now i assume that how old was the oldest
dog on record so i assumed that uh i was
gonna phrase this
i was gonna phrase this more directly i
assume it's dead
um
this is a complete gap in my knowledge
because it's about animals i don't know
how long
i don't know how long a dog lives
i should know that
i'm going to regret this
i'm going to say 32 years
because i feel like that's the end of
the bell curve the the longest second
yeah i think you've got this because
i've gone more conservative with 26.
i mean how long
like
how long does an average dog live
i don't know i think
i think sadly it's not as long as a cat
it's
your answer
this is uh this by the way is for
dingo psycho hot sauce 15 out of 10 heat
warning
29 years and five months
i think that's your hot sauce
why did i have to save five months
oh mate i'm sorry
i'm so sorry
oh i could have just put 27. you could
have just turned this down i touched my
eyes oh no
oh no i think i'm all right
i just put my fingers in my eyes
gav i'm so sorry ah i didn't
oh
you must you must have
smarter youtube friends that could you
could have brought on for a more equal
game i didn't
the smart one said no i genuinely
thought you'd be better at this than i
am yeah
i'll see you over there yeah
sorry
i'll describe this before i can't speak
yeah imagine a small steamroller
but the flat roller is small knives yeah
just slowly driving towards the back of
the throat there that was a full force
arrival but it had no mass to it
i swear they don't put the strongest one
at the end
well the last one is is the the last dab
one that they do right yeah
i mean that was by no means
mild yeah if i was rating them so far
it'd be you know everything up here this
one would be on this side of this yeah
all right so what happened there is
if i can describe it this one
was a you know really slow didn't really
understand where it was going
this one came in much higher yep
just never got to the same height so
that was more worrying
but much more relieving and you're still
not on the milk still on the milk
i feel like i am getting some sort of
stacking effect from the last year
yeah okay
but i think with that one i think i've
got away with that mind you the ice
cream's just sitting here melting at
this point yeah
you got the eraser let's let's go for
the last jab
so this is the last dab apollo made with
the apollo pepper the new world record
hottest pepper
oh look at the liquidy yeah the
viscosity of that one yeah okay
what is the current fastest speed run
time of super mario bros in minutes
seconds
and milliseconds
i know nothing about video games
the only the only clue in that is
milliseconds sorry like honestly my
first thought on that was like
half an hour
but it says minutes seconds milliseconds
speed runs you know sort of stop watch
based a lot of the time aren't they so
they just stop the clock and yeah
and sometimes even if it minutes seconds
even if it's half an hour you might get
people ending around the half an hour
mark which is why okay oh yeah it's
important yeah is what i'm trying to say
okay
which
i'm trying to visualize
i i don't know where to start with this
there's got to be what warp pipes
involved
sure
do what you really don't play games i i
played video games when i was a kid uh i
think the
it's been
10 15 years since i seriously played
anything and
like i was never i was never a console
kid so
i don't even know
in hindsight i should have gone for a
funny number i should have put you know
like 12 000 yeah
i should have been 12 000 or i should
have gone for like you know 69 something
but what i've done is i've gone for 24
minutes and then just put some put some
random numbers on there okay i've gone
for three minutes 20.
um i feel
i feel like i might know how this one
ends
i don't
i know i've seen some mario games done
very fast i just don't know which one
that was
so what i need here is for this to say
like over 15 is where i'm starting to
look good that's um
yeah it's just under five minutes that's
it's over for me it is
it's not for me
that is a significant dab i'm
i'm
going all out you've got it you've got
it i can't i can't go half-assed on this
can i no i guess not it is youtube after
all
oh
seems pleasant maybe i see why he said
it's just wet there's nothing
oh seriously
i was almost disappointed
shoulda gone never walked by the paints
oh
that
takes ten seconds and then
that was interesting your reaction at
the beginning was
almost disappointment in even in you
ah
so
i'm gonna dial 9-1 just so
the subtitles team that we have for this
channel
do already nope milk i'm oh on the milk
i couldn't be happier i couldn't be
happier
the subtitles
do a great job
because
i mean i have to ask them to calm down
because like
they over describe stuff
like
the subtitles should not distract from
the content
so
i can i can hear in your throat i sleep
get that milk down do you feel all right
but in this case subtitle team
go on go ahead and
just add all the descriptive stuff you
want in these vocalizations
wet blubbering
is it just continuing to build or is it
do you think you're over the hump
i still feel mine i can't imagine what
you're going through right now
you want to get the ice cream going
yes
for both of us
we should have pre-opened this mate
let me take care of this
just
oh that's nice and soft well you won't
struggle with the uh
the plastic spoon there
it has been waiting there like half an
hour that oh that's just that's liquid
cool
okay that's just
oh
yeah i'll give it a go why not
i'm good
see that's fine
that gets real can you pass the
the kitchen roll
that ah
just it just comes back
[Applause]
ah
we've come a long way
thanks cap
anytime
never again